who Denmark was very lucky to have as
their immigration integration minister
in 2015 until 2019. ingest toyberg was
the most important figure to make sure
that Denmark did not make the mistakes
Sweden did in 20 Fin and taking hundreds
of thousands of people who then couldn't
integrate Denmark didn't do that largely
because of Angus Freiburg
autismburg's reward been for keeping her
country's borders secure she has been
prosecuted in Denmark she was sentenced
to prison for effectively defending the
borders of Denmark she had to wear an
ankle bracelet so when Maloney or any
other European politician is looking at
this if you do the wrong thing and you
make sure that you just allow a constant
flow of illegals into country you will
retire fine if you do the right thing
and enforce your country's orders you
are likely very likely to face the rest
of your life in the courts